The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have teeth hello
everyone thank you all for being here
Tom I'm actually going to start with you
because fans of The Hunger Game series
are very familiar I think with this book
but for folks that aren't your character
is probably the one that they most
associate with the series but they're
going to go into it sort of the same way
I did with your character where they may
have it familiar but we're getting to
see a completely different side of your
character so I'd love for you to tell us
about the cornelus snowy sea in this
version of The Hunger Games yeah Cory
lanus at this point in his life is still
relatively innocent um he's not
undergone the kind of transformation to
become future president of panm and
future Tyrant of panm um um he is at
this point in the story uh still like a
cousin brother to Tigress he's a
grandson to grandom he's still got love
in his heart he's not lost hope yet um
and for me that was what was so
interesting about playing him is like
getting to lift the lid and kind of look
at him before he under goes that
transformation um I think that's what's
exciting for the fans too is getting to
like see a character who they think they
know and kind of have their expectations
challenged a little bit Yeah but we see
glimpses let be real by The End by the
end as as the transformation happens
throughout the film by the end you see
him you see who he's going to be yeah
it's interesting though seeing a
different version of him because I will
say the most interesting character to
brush up against that new version is the
lady sitting to your left and Lucy gray
and everything that I think she does to
him in this movie Echoes throughout the
entire Series so Rachel I'd love for you
to talk about Lucy and how she not only
lives in a different version of PanAm
but a different version of the seam and
District 12 and what she means to that
Community when we find her okay book fan
with the seam I love it get there girl I
mean I I think this this movie is so
much focused on nature versus nurture
and you really get to see how the
different perspectives of one's life
shape who they're going to be um I think
kind of I think tigress's character
really puts it the best when she asks
cor lanus what if it was your name that
they pulled wouldn't you want to know
that someone still cared about you and
uh and how how she defends Lucy gray to
grandm and says she's she's just a girl
she's not the people who were you know
fighting in the war and so getting to
see her interactions with quanus having
such different upbringing than he did
makes it such a dynamic relationship and
it kind of leaves you wondering at the
end you know are we are we ever really
going to make it or are we just too
different and and seeing how Echoes of
her personality and who she is kind of
haunt him for the rest of his life in
Katniss everine in the original trilogy
it's it's a really cool thing to get to
play with you've already alluded to one
of the biggest controversies among book
fans and since you've already called me
out on my fandom I will mention this
it's the idea of like did these two
characters who are in this quasi Love
Story did they love each other or were
they using each other I really I I want
to start with where your vote is and
then also how did you play it so Tom
I'll start with you where do you vote
are they did they so tricky I keep
getting asked this question and it's a
really good question because it kind of
flumes me every time because I don't
think I have an answer for it I think
like Suzanne Collins is really good at
is asking the big questions but not
necessarily providing an answer she
provides like characters and
circumstances that kind of challenge the
question and kind of let you walk away
with with your own answer I guess um but
I guess I'm not letting you C
out I knew you wouldn't I'm trying my
best to cop out I guess you know what if
I had to pick one I would say they are
in love for a for a short time um short
but sweet time but like is it love of
circumstance like is it is it born out
of circumstance and out of Need for each
other and then the question is like what
even is love like can love does love
have to be just like this pure thing
that comes out of nowhere or is
sometimes is it out of circumstance and
is it out of like what one person needs
from another um so yeah I would say yes
but yeah how hard was it to to that
balance like did you guys have okay on
this day I love you on this day I hate
you on this day I'm not sure how did you
sort of keep the the push and pull of
the characters straight I know for me
like a lot of that kind of confus with
each other and they kind of um The
Challenge between them and the kind of
uh the Crux of the imbalance of power
that they're they're fighting is like
the ambiguity of it like I think Coro
was looking at her thinking I love her
but she feels dangerous to me she feels
like the very chaos that he's been
taught you have to control in order to
have a like a flourishing society that
he wants to live in like she kind of
represents the chaos and the kind of the
the fire and the you know the music and
the life and he's been taught that you
have to like squash all that in order to
have control and be powerful and
ironically he represents a very similar
thing for her because she views the
capital as disorder and you view the
districts as dis and uh and I feel like
when we were approaching our scenes
together it was mostly for me at least
what percentage of her doubts what he's
saying to her right now on this given
day um because she doesn't really know
for for a majority of it the first thing
that happens between the two of us is
the guards say that you want to help me
but you also get money so which is it I
say both yeah and and it's there is like
an unbridled honesty to a certain extent
that makes you want to root for them but
the reality is that either both of them
are are very much team self-preservation
and survival so your team love butt I'm
also team love but team love
but you said that not me and the
internet will have its day um Hunter I
will say um the great thing about this
version of snow that we get is that he
is human humanized in almost instantly
and I would say your character is doing
so much heavy lifting let me just talk
about it cuz I did not um go into both
um reading about this character and also
watching them on screen thinking that so
I'd love for you to talk about again how
she is her own person very much in that
but she's always reminding of him
humanity and and maybe as we watch her
transformation that's also when he loses
that M yeah I mean I think like on on a
bigger level I feel like the universe
sometimes puts people in other people's
lives like purely because they need them
you know and I think that's probably how
tigis uh has felt for most of her life
and and it's not even a question for her
uh by the time we meet her in the movie
um uh so I think it it like when we meet
her it's it's only second nature for her
to feel like I think her her core
purpose is to is to you know um support
and like and and keep Coro like grounded
in this like crazy world that they have
to navigate um um so yeah I think it's
like completely integral to like who she
is as a person um also I will add there
is obviously a always with The Hunger
Games great sort of I would say moments
of costuming and fashion and everything
and I will say even for post Revolution
very sort of like Rundown Capital but it
was nice to see that she was slaying
some looks but that also meant you got
to talk to the costumers I think because
for your character what she's wearing is
a huge part of the character and
everything I I think for you that was
probably extra added fun as a fashion
girl absolutely I mean the way Tigers
navigates fashion totally reminds me of
how I used to like back when I lived in
North Carolina and like you know we
don't even have like Zara in North
Carolina like like so I my way of like
like um I don't know making clothes and
being able to participate in fashion was
like going to the thrift store and then
cutting things up and sewing them and
whatever and I think um that's kind of
exactly how tigis comes at it too uh you
know just with their lack of resources
and uh dressing not only herself up but
Coro up to play the game yeah playing
the game she helps him hide she helps
him navigate everything I love that
that's a good way of putting it yeah
Josh I will say for your character um as
much as like tigers she gives armor your
character gives not just Humanity but
ethics and morality and and that's
something maybe that Lucy needs at
certain points in the arena and also all
the other characters as well but I will
say you already stepped on to some great
sets both you and Rachel stepped on to
step Spielberg set for Westside Story
has to be kind of awesome though to have
scenes with Viola Davis and Peter
Dinklage and like the other casts um
also even like Josh and what he brings
to the table talk about stepping onto a
Hunger Game set not only as a fan but
knowing you had this incredible cast
with you yeah I mean obviously that
comes with a healthy amount of impostor
syndrome for a little while you know
until you have time to sort of get
comfortable it was a colossal learning
experience and a real master class to be
able to you know act with these guys and
also act with Viola Peter and Jason um I
really spent a lot of time just trying
to absorb the kind of professionalism
and the um you know caliber of
performance that they brought to the
table and just do my best to kind of uh
mimic that I guess to some degree you
know it's it's really terrific I've been
very lucky your character again for
folks that are fans of The Hunger Games
they've definitely read him but he's a
newer character for folks in this one
more so even than Lucy who's sort of
referenced I think a little bit or sort
of like is a ghost of the games can you
tell us a little bit about who he is and
how he relates to everyone else here
he's a he's a man of heart he wears his
heart on his sleeve uh he's got he's got
really really strong convictions he's
originally district and was able to come
to to the capital because his dad made a
lot of money and became Rich enough to
move to the capital and because of that
there's a fair amount of resentment that
he has for his
environment and I think because of that
he's able to clock that Cory elanus is
is not the polished wealthy sort of
paragon that he tries to pretend to be
and there's kind of a relationship that
gets built from that and uh he just
really believes in in in the good of
humanity and and people's capacity to to
do good and in particular C elus his
capacity to do good and his potential to
be a good person and he faces adversity
because of that and there's a really
beautiful amount of tension because of
it adversity is a very kind way of
playing that but I love you for making
sure folks pay attention because they're
going to get to go through a lot with
your character um I will bring it back
to your character Tom because he sort of
alludes to it and that is the duplicity
and the duplicity that he has even with
himself I think as a person but also
what he's doing to this because even in
the story we see him at two very
different points um both I would say
like the hair tells the story a little
bit it does but um what was that like
for you sort of like embodying him
through I would say a very different not
even a character Arc almost like a
character divot yeah you know the image
that comes to mind is I don't know if
you ever read these books as a kid but
where you get to like choose your own
path and if you you know you turn up to
a certain page you get to go down that
path instead of the other one I feel
like watching Coro go through this movie
is like watching him kind of at the at
the most pivotal point of his choose the
choose your own path story
um and he keeps kind of choosing the
slightly more murky more complicated
path every time um which is the most
interesting one and also the most like
like heartbreaking one um so for me I
mean like getting to getting to play
that is always fascinating you know
getting to play the kind of duality of a
person um and I think like me as an
actor as well as the audience are kind
of rooting for him to like even though
we know where he ends up which is the
amazing thing about this story that
Suzanne has written is like you know
where he ends up and yet you can watch
this and still be rooting for him to
like make the right choice and do the
right thing um and then when he may or
may not you know you're kind of like
heartbroken with tigress and with
Grandma and with Lucy gray I would
imagine that a lot of actors talk about
how this more Sinister sides are more
fun to play did that also make the more
tender loving side more difficult to
play knowing that let's be real like
when you're in your juices on that it
might be a little bit easier yeah if
anything actually I think it was like a
breath of fresh air like when I go to
play like the love moment with with
Rachel or like the really like heartfelt
moments with with with HTO and Tigress
um like that those days were just like
oh thank God I get to like bre the
breath of fresh a today because the the
darker moments are you know towards the
end it gets heavy he he gets kind of
heavy um and especially the breaking
point um so to get to play the the
lightness from time to time and also
just like be able to see why why you
might like him at the beginning um cuz
it's hard to understand why you might
like this guy when we know where he ends
up um but I think that's that's the cool
thing thing about the the book in in in
the first place is like getting to
getting to kind of like remember the
humanity of it all and remember like
that everyone starts off as like an
innocent until they're not um yeah I
find that interesting I I feel everyone
would be upset with me if I didn't
mention the music of this one um because
that has been such a big feature of both
the trailers and everything and I don't
think the music intimidated you but um
it is an added bonus in addition to the
physical aspects of the performance and
and everything you have to do to bring
Lucy to life what do you think what was
it for you was it refreshing was it an
escape was it something where like was
what was more challenging adding on the
music or maybe adding on all the
physicality definitely the action bits
are so much more than I've ever had to
do before you know other movies I've had
stunts that I just simply wasn't allowed
to do move on this one was 95% I did all
my own stunts and it was without much
preparation and just a lot of care and a
lot of patience from the people around
me so that definitely was the added
pressure and a lot of intimidation for
me which made the music scenes feel like
okay I've got this a nice deep breath
this is like coming home this is like
second nature to me and and I always
feel like when I'm on a set and I get to
know my crew I'm getting to know all of
their talents so well that it feels
really exciting to get to bring one of
mine to the table um because it's more
than just getting to like say words on a
screen it's like getting to stepen
sonheim once said that you you sing when
it the emotion is too great for speaking
and it's really wonderful that Lucy gray
gets so many moments that are so
emotional that she can't speak anymore
and she has to sing all right so what
was the hardest action sequence then I
mean definitely like the the blood bath
the the beginning of the games because
it was a lot of camera choreography and
God bless our crew they were just
pushing me out of the way to just make
sure that I didn't die in the process
watching you run through that forest and
those heels was pretty pretty intense
too all of it was in heels that was
really the thing trille serve a look
trille said no flats and no zippers
those were tied up every day oh man
that's torturous that that needs to be
on the tagline like and and in heels
like very Ginger during that um the
other thing I loved is that when I was
researching this all of you at one point
are screaming I was such a big Hunger
Games fan I ran through the book or I
was obsessed with this um that means
that the call I don't know when in the
audition process even maybe when they
even say they're interested in you had
to be like a freakout moment so I would
like all of you to maybe sort of let me
know on your freak out moment either
when they said they were interested in
you or better yet probably when you got
the part and I'll start with your AEL I
hung up on my
agent I hung up on him he said Francis
Lawrence said you're his number one
choice for Lucy gray and I hung up the
phone I panicked I don't really know
didn't call back for three
months I hopefully he took that the
right way yeah I know it was it was
amazing and and because I had kind of
bothered my one of my other agents after
I read the book in 2020 saying I wanted
do this what are they doing and she was
like Lions Gate has optioned it Francis
has attached to direct but it's the
pandemic nobody's moving on anything I
said that makes sense and then in uh
2022 I got the phone call and it was
really amazing so that's mine what about
you I I go speechless whenever I get
like big news I really do like lose
words um and I I definitely like all my
agents called me up and they're like
four four or five people on the phone
and first of all four or five people on
the phone is a nightmare like waiting
waiting to see who's going to speak and
I'm like so I just I just go silent and
uh and then I think they wonder if if
I've hung up um but no I'm just sat
there like going uh so yeah that was
that was my experience was literally
speechless speechless and then you have
to keep it a secret because then and
then you got to keep it a secret and
like you can't tell your family or when
you do tell your family like you have to
promise not to say anything although it
was you it you I'll come for you the
threats come out yeah started channeling
Coro straight away I love it I like
don't cross me H what about you um I
feel like when when good things happen
they don't actually register in my head
that it's a thing that's happening until
I'm there so I don't think I really had
my freakout moment until I was like I
don't know how did restart I think until
like I was on the set and by the way
everything's like practical like there's
literally almost no green screen so it
really just felt like I was
like I'm in
panic
and um I think that was the moment I
want to teach her this is I'm in
Ser the hashtag let's
go yeah I I I have the tendency to be
kind of a cynic I feel like so when I
got the audition request I was like well
I'm not going to get
this so I I did it uh you know I did I
did the tape I was in a rush and I uh
told somebody else I this is really bad
but I you know I I I had the iPad here
under the camera and and when I would
look at the line I would pretend that I
was
thinking
uh he's a really good actor I can't
believe you're sharing this yeah I would
not be sharing this stop it
going Hey listen but I did the research
before I did that but I didn't do didn't
learn the
line uh but then I got a call back
so then it started to get a little bit
more real and I was like oh gosh I got
to really work on this I did the call
back uh and I knew the lines I was just
about to say but then at that point
aren't you like well it worked the first
time so now I've got to never learn
lines again because then unfortunately
what happens is I do this like Blas
thing and I think it becomes really
honest because I do that and then when I
and then when I want it it's like oh my
gosh and then I get really
nervous um but you know then uh
then I got the call back and uh I I I
was able to you know I guess I guess do
it I still even then though I was quite
skeptical but uh you know then I got the
call and I was kind of like
what no no and it wasn't really until I
was on my way to Berlin that I was like
I think I'm doing this movie it wasn't
until they announced you that you were
like I got it I can't take it back now
yeah exactly exactly they already posted
on socials they can't take it back
that's a more real actor thing cuz like
we know things sometimes especially go
away you can't lose it at the last
minute yeah yeah I'm going to just call
y'all hunger gam super fans you could
lie I could be lying about you but
that's where I'm leaving I think it's
it's we are okay good time then you know
that a lot of folks are like we love
this as it is and like so for those
folks I'd love for you all to maybe sort
of give I'll start with you Rachel
because I think you've got the tagline
for like this is why you need to come to
this one because I think they're going
to see a lot of different things in a
world that they probably think they
already know even if they did read the
book right I think as a fan of something
getting the Back stories about stuff is
always so interesting and and so much of
the the heart of the fandom are the
diard fans and and the reason we make
these films and the reason we've been
able to come back and and make this
prequel um they're going to get the
games that they know and love but
they're going to get the why which is
really really interesting cuz I feel
like in the original trilogy you get to
examine so much of the world of penm but
never its history so I I really think
that's a reason enough to come and and
you don't only get the really
interesting backstory of a villain but
you get the the background of the
rebellion and the Revolution and it I
think it's such a compelling story about
so many different facets and I really
think fans are going to have such a
wonderful time and newcomers to the
series are going to want to go and
rewatch The Original Trilogy after and
y'all are kind of dreamy like let's I'm
like watching you on the interview and
I'm like I seeing it I'm like y'all are
kind of dreamy in those those moments
I'm going to put that out there for the
romance book reader is people I'm going
to put that out there I'm like there's
some dreamy moments too I will say that
in between all the
Carnage Tom I'll put it down for you on
this last one because again this is in a
lot of ways a prequel of President Snow
that we eventually get to see but I know
you didn't want it to be what Donald
suland did in the trilogy you wanted to
make it your own but I'm sure there was
very key things that Francis said to you
he wanted to make sure stay true can you
maybe communicate what those sort of
like core things were to where we could
maybe see yes a different version of
this character but know that it's going
to end up where it ends up at the end
yeah it's interesting because actually
was the opposite Francis wanted me to
stay away from like trying to do
anything that Donald did um he like was
really adamant that he wanted it to be a
totally fresh take and that we had kind
of like 64 years of of license like
creative license to kind of make it our
own um but I as a fan of like this book
and also the original films I was like
how can you watch this and not like want
to see some of those mannerisms in there
um or like just that that he's got like
such a specific spe ific way of like
speaking his Cadence and his rhythms um
which make that performance so like
delicious um and I was like but I like I
would want to see that if I was watching
this film I would want to see that so I
was like how do I put that in and then I
realized it's like oh you can get there
as the film goes on like he he ends in a
very different place to where he begins
so I gave myself kind of the Freedom At
the beginning to make him just a young
man who is ambitious and hungry and like
wanting to do ride by his family and and
whatever that meant to me and like where
that lived in my body and then by act
three of this film he's very much on his
way and that's when you start to see
like President Snow coming in a little
bit and like just the way he speaks the
way he holds himself um and I definitely
took a little bit of inspiration from
from the original President Snow for
that because I don't know he's just like
that one step closer to being President
Snow the Tyrant um he's still got a long
way to go he still got like 60 63 and a
half years um but like you want to see
him kind of on the way by the end yeah
all right I'm gonna ask arisuin because
I know we don't have any other source
material and everybody is going to trust
in what Suzanne Collins has done at this
point but some people would like to know
if you guys hope this could be the start
of something more because I mean there's
like 65 years in between there's a lot
that they could do do you want to do
it like yeah I think we'd all love to I
think we all agree it would have to come
from Suzanne and and Francis and Nina
but we would love to come back yeah I
feel like there's a lot more to to
discover with this yeah
this this is an easy crowd to be like as
I don't have to learn any
lines perfect well thank you
thank thank y'all so much I really
appreciate it and congratulations again
thank
dope